[Music]
hi I'm Don mr. t I'm a program manager
on the Microsoft translator team and I'm
here to tell you about a new product
from the team called Microsoft
translator now it's the world's first
true conversation translation tool and
you must notice it as I'm speaking the
transcription of what I'm saying is
showing up right here it's not
completely accurate but you'll see that
it's carrying most of what I'm saying
and as I'm speaking along with the
English on the left you also see the
Chinese so this is a live translation of
what I am saying in English in Chinese
and this is a really crucial tool for
Education scenarios for business
scenarios for travel scenarios where two
or more people speaking multiple
languages need to talk to one another so
let me give you another example of how
someone on their smartphone could
connect into this conversation so right
here I have the Microsoft translator app
on my Android device
I am going to look at my conversation
code here and pull up the QR code
and using my device here I'm going to
scan the QR code
[Music]
and select French as my language sure I
don't speak very much French but just
about to get by so washer comma Sava
so as you see here you see the French of
what that I broke this nice ah you see
the French of what the water said in
French showing up here in English and
what I'm saying in English shows up here
in French and as before continues to
show up here in Chinese so this is not
just a dental it's a real product today
downloaded on Android iOS Windows
PowerPoint and web look for Microsoft
translator the app on your smart phone
of choice thank you very much